LET YOU KNOW WERE DOING OUR
BEST RUDY GIULIANI IMPRESSION
DURING THE BREAK.
MOVING ON TO SERIOUS MATTERS,
JOE BIDEN WAS ASKED WHETHER HE
SHOULD HAVE TOLD HIS SON
HUNTER NOT TAKE A SEAT ON THE
BOARD OF UKRAINIAN GAS
COMPANY.
>> HE WAS ALREADY ON THE BOARD
AND HE'S A GROWN MAN.
AS IT TURNS OUT HE DID NOT DO
A SINGLE THING WRONG.
>> THAT IS NOT TRUE.
HUNTER BIDEN WAS NOT ALREADY
ON THE BOARD.
IN EARLY 2014, VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN WAS PUT IN CHARGE OF
UKRAINE POLICY ON APRIL 16 HE
MET WITH CHARISMA BOARD MEMBER
AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND TWO
DAYS LATER, AFTER THAT HIS SON
HUNTER JOINED THE COMPANY.
THREE DAYS AFTER THAT BIDEN
WENT TO UKRAINE AND PUSHED FOR
MORE GAS PRODUCTION.
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS, WHILE
HUNTER WAS ON THE BOARD, HIS
FATHER WHO BOASTED ON CAMERA
ABOUT CONTROLLING USAID
OVERSAW BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT WENT TO UKRAINE INCLUDING
TO THE GAS INDUSTRY.
NOW WERE IN NEW YORK TONIGHT,
RUDY GIULIANI IF YOU'RE
WATCHING AT BACK TO STAGE WHAT
IS KNOWN AS AN INTERVENTION OR
A REDIRECT.
THE PRESIDENT SAID RUDY IS A
GREAT CORRUPTION FIGHTER.
>> RUDY GIULIANI IS A FINE MAN.
HE WAS THE GREATEST MARE IN
THE HISTORY OF NEW YORK AND
HE'S BEEN ONE OF THE GREATEST
CRIME FIGHTERS AND CORRUPTION
FIGHTERS.
>> SO RUDY, CAN YOU PLEASE
REDIRECT YOUR CORRUPTION
INVESTIGATION EFFORTS TO FOCUS
ON THE REAL QUESTION WE NEED
ANSWERS TO, HOW MUCH U.S.
TAXPAYER AID WENT TO A
UKRAINIAN COMPANY THAT WAS
PAYING JOE BIDEN'S SON WHILE
JOE BIDEN WAS IN CHARGE OF THE
EIGHT.
THAT'S THE CORRUPTION, THAT'S
WHAT NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
OKAY.
THE REASON I WANT TO BE CLEAR
WITH THIS REDIRECTION IS
BECAUSE I FEEL THE STORY ON
ALL THIS HAS GOTTEN UP BIT
MURKY AND MUDDIED.
THERE IS A CLEAR LINK BETWEEN
BIDEN, THE AIDE AND THE GAS
COMPANY BUT WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH MONEY.
>> THERE IS A TIMELINE AND AS
YOU KNOW, THE MEDIA IS NOT
PRESSING ON THIS.
NORA O'DONNELL HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY BUT SHE DIDN'T SAY
ANYTHING.
THERE'S AN INTERESTING
PHENOMENON.
I'VE BEEN GOING TO ALL THE
DEBATES IN TALKING WITH
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS, THEY CARE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
THEY THINK IT'S SHADY, THE
OTHER CANDIDATES REFUSED TO
CALL HIM OUT ON THIS.
IT'S VERY TROUBLING TO ME
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN THIS
KUMBAYA COME UP PROTECT UNCLE
JOE, THIS IS A PRIMARY.
ANYTHING THAT ANY CANDIDATE
HAD DONE, ANY BIT OF
CORRUPTION, IF IT WAS SHADY
THEY ALL WENT AFTER EACH
OTHER.
THE DEMOCRAT, IF THEY HAD ANY
GUTS THEY WOULD GO AFTER JOE
BIDEN AND HUNTER BECAUSE THE
VOTERS CARE ABOUT IT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE
VARNEY AND ELIZABETH WARREN
WHO SAY THEY WANT TO FIGHT
CORRUPTION AND THIS IS
HAPPENING.
>> THE REASON WHY THIS
MATTERS, EVERYBODY SAY WHAT
ABOUT THE TRUMP CHILDREN, WHAT
ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS WHY IT MATTERS.
WHEN JOE BIDEN SAT DOWN AND
DID HIS FIRST INTERVIEW AND
WAS ASKED WHAT IS YOUR
CAMPAIGN SLOGAN GOING TO BE
AND HE SAID I'M GOING TO MAKE
AMERICA MORAL AGAIN, HE'S
GOING TO REFORM INTEGRITY.
HE HAS MADE THE CENTERPIECE OF
HIS CAMPAIGN ABOUT PRISTINE,
THAT HE'S GONNA BE PRISTINE
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CORRUPT
AND HORRIBLE AND A BUSINESSMAN
AND TRYING TO MAKE MONEY,
TRYING TO PROFIT AND LO AND
BEHOLD HERE HE IS DOING THE
EXACT SAME THING HE'S ACCUSING
THE OTHER PERSON.
IF YOU MAKE THAT YOUR
CENTERPIECE YOU ARE GOING TO
CHOKE ON YOUR OWN MORAL FIBER
BECAUSE WITHOUT QUESTION.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> THIS IS PART OF THE
IMPEACHMENT THING, THAT WILL
END AT SOME POINT WILL HAVE
THE IMPEACHMENT IT WILL ALL GO
AWAY, NO ONE REALLY THANKS IT
WILL RESULT IN REMOVING
PRESIDENT TRUMP FROM OFFICE SO
WE WILL MOVE ON.
BENNETT WILL BE CHINA.
THERE'S A LOT TO INVESTIGATE
THEIR AND JOE BIDEN'S BROTHER
AND THE CONTRACT TO REBUILD
IRAQ.
IT'S ENDLESS IN THE MATERIAL
HERE.
>> I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
BELIEVES HE WAS AWARE THAT HIS
SON WAS DOING ALL THIS
BUSINESS DEALINGS THAT
HAPPENED TO COINCIDE WITH
PLACES HE WAS DEEPLY INVOLVED
IN.
I THINK THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT
SMARTER THAN THAT.
BUT HERE'S THE THING, CLEARLY
OF THE JOE BIDEN CAMPAIGN IS
CONCERNED.
[INAUDIBLE]
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE TRYING
TO TELL THESE TELEVISION
NETWORKS YOU SHOULDN'T PUT
GIULIANI ON, THEY'RE TRYING TO
CAN CONTROL THE NARRATIVE.
SENDING LETTERS THAT THEY TAKE
DOWN ADS ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN,
CLEARLY THERE'S CONCERN.
YOU LOOK AT THEM ATTACKING THE
NEW YORK TIMES FOR RUNNING THE
ALP ED BY PETER THAT'S TALKING
ABOUT THESE EXACT THINGS.
OR THIS ETHICS PLEDGE THING
THAT BASICALLY DOES WOULDN'T
HAPPEN UNDER HIS
ADMINISTRATION AND YOU
HAPPEN.
>> TO YOUR POINT THAT WHEN HE
SAYS WE NEVER TALKED ABOUT IT,
ARE YOU KIDDING ME YOU SAY
WHERE YOU WORKING THESE DAYS?
UKRAINE.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S NOT LIKE IT'S DETROIT.
THAT'S KIND OF A BIG THING.
I THINK IT WOULD'VE COME UP IN
CONVERSATION.
>> THE LIES CONTINUE BECAUSE
EVEN AFTER HUNTER BIDEN AND HE
MAGICALLY APPEARED AGAIN, HE
SAID HE DIDN'T KNOW HUNTER WAS
GETTING READY TO GIVE AN
INTERVIEW.